- Here are a few things you should
probably be doing with your shirts.
When wearing a white dress shirt,
undershirts of the same
color usually show through.
A grey undershirt is
typically less visible,
as it more closely matches
the value of skintone.
An easy way to get a good sleeve roll
is to pull the cuff up like so,
and fold the sleeve over it here.
Jack Kennedy did it this way,
so it's probably good enough for you.
Simply shoving your shirt into your pants
can cause severe muffin-topping.
To get a clean tuck, grab
the bottom of the shirt
and fold the fabric
back at the side seams.
This hides extra fabric and is great
for shirts that are particularly wide.
Or you could just buy
shirts that actually fit.
And while we're on the subject of tucking,
shirts with the longer, curved tails
are designed to be tucked.
Shirts with flat bottoms are better suited
for leaving untucked.
And those little sleeves on your collar
are for collar stays.
Use them to achieve a
more clean, formal look.
Want to update an old shirt?
You can turn a shirt
collar into a band collar.
Simply cut off the collar here.
You can also pull the stitching,
remove the collar, and resew it,
but you're probably gonna [bleep] that up.
(African percussion music)